also new this morning well she's going
to spend this year's Super Bowl with on
her way that is fantastic guess who is
going to the Super Bowl her name is
Sandra and she's a special Olympian and
she's got two tickets to the big game
this year in Arizona now the act of
kindness made possible by Raiders punter
A.J Cole who facetimed Sandra yesterday
to congratulate her for the past seven
years she's been involved in the Special
Olympics competing in track and field
and so from all of us here at Good Day
Las Vegas a big congratulations to her
hope she has a great time it's a big
game love to see the Special Olympics
athletes getting to go see all these big
events